what's going on guys this is rob and i
am getting ready to go see doctor
strange too in like three hours so yes
this video is going up but i'm ignoring
everything i'm not responding to any
comments i'm not reading any comments
i'm not getting on social media nothing
like this is one movie where i don't
want anything spoiled for me however for
reasons that i'll never fully understand
one of you guys asked me to make a video
explaining the incursions but as you
guys know i love jonathan hickman's
avengers and new avengers and i will
take any opportunity to talk about it so
let's talk about the incursions
i love oh my god i love the incursions
god i love jonathan hickman's avengers
and new avengers god it's so good for
those of you guys who never who are
never part of like our original coverage
one you are missing out like dude it was
one of the best things to like watch
fans like in the comments as we were
covering it they're like it's the
greatest story ever uh and two you'll
find the whole playlist down in the
description so here's the thing about
the incursions what i'm about to tell
you happens in the first three issues
it's nuts one day black panther's
hanging out
and basically like i think it's a
rhinoceros just comes running through
what looks like an invisible wall and
black panther is like what in the hell
is going on with that so he goes to
investigate and when he passes through
he basically sees a red earth and so
he's like okay this is really weird but
then there's also this chick named black
swan who shows up she kind of like
descends down from this earth and then
basically black panther fights them all
ends up capturing her and then he
reforms the illuminati and what's like
one of the best black panther moments
ever okay so it's so good it's so
amazing that like at the at the end of
this there's this moment where black
panther he's praying to the panther
goddess best right and he's like goddess
oh god has saved me from what this world
demands what he's like save me from
righteous men save me from thinkers save
me from summoners like save me from
midnight kings and the devil himself
he's talking about like neymar the
submariner because like the last time
they met neymar the submariner had
basically like attacked wakanda during
the events of avengers versus x-men and
like pretty much obliterated wakanda so
like black panther has like a blood feud
with uh with with like men with a
submariner now but nonetheless right so
so basically black panther reforms the
illuminati which includes captain
america right we're not gonna cover the
entirety of hikman's avengers and new
events by the way just talk about the
incursions here but you guys can't yeah
you understand man i can't help myself
the story is just that damn good once
the illuminati's reformed reed richards
basically interrogates black swan and
that's when you get what they initially
believe to be the cause of the
incursions like literally black swan you
end up finding out she has no clue what
the hell is going on but she spouts her
her views with such conviction that like
you think she knows what's actually
happening but she basically talks about
raboo mall and like the the great
destroyer and like the the wheel has to
turn and like basically the idea behind
the incursions is that somewhere along
the line an entire universe was
obliterated right that earth was was
basically destroyed and the universe was
annihilated along with it and when that
happened it basically pushed the two
universes next to it into the universes
next to them creating what was basically
a domino effect now earth is the anchor
point so when an incursion happened like
it did at the beginning of the story and
you basically saw an alternate earth out
there just kind of floating in the ether
what happens is that from the time that
earth appears you basically have eight
hours by the time that eight hours
reaches zero those earths will collide
and both universes will be destroyed
however the only way to stave off an
incursion is to destroy one of those
earths now when that whole realization
happens again we're still sticking with
like the first three issues that
jonathan hickman's new avengers run this
is how epic it was so what ends up going
on here
[Laughter]
is that essentially the illuminati are
like well there's only one thing we can
do so they gather the infinity stones
right all the infinity gems and they
assemble the infinity gauntlet and when
they're trying to figure out who it is
to wield it they ultimately decide
captain america should be the one to use
the infinity stones and so he grabs the
gauntlet and he like pushes the
alternate earth away but in the process
all the infinity stones are destroyed
except for the time stone which
disappears so basically when the
infinity gauntlet fails as a as a resort
the illuminati are just like we got to
start blowing up worlds but captain
america doesn't want to captain america
is like no i'm not okay with that and so
under the direction of iron man doctor
strange wipes the mind of captain
america and throws him out of the
illuminati so he has no idea what
they're doing later on during original
sin he remembers and by this point he's
just this crotchy old son of a [ __ ] who
lost his healing factor or lost his
super soldier serum so he's like hunting
the illuminati with like the full might
of shield it's amazing but nonetheless
following that basically it's just earth
smashing into each other and like read
richard to the fantastic four makes a
multiversal bridge so they can look into
other realities and see how other
realities are handling the incursions of
things along those lines dr strange
tries to sell his soul at the sinner's
market and he can't because he has like
a corrupted soul and incomplete soul so
we can't have basically the power of god
he only gets like like most of it right
i mean you know i don't know what most
of god's power is like what's most of
infinity i don't know like 900 billion i
have no idea so at the end of the story
what you end up learning is it was
actually dr doom who basically caused
the incursions to happen but it was
unintentional it was an accidental thing
you had a group of beings out there from
the beyond verse that were referred to
as the beyonders nobody ever said marvel
was great when it came to names but the
important thing here is that these guys
had been around for quite some time but
they had just now basically constructed
their experiment that what you have
across
really in every single universe in
marvel comics is you have the molecule
man owen reese this guy is a universal
constant in every single universe his
origin is the exact same and in every
single universe his power set is the
exact same the ability to alter reality
on a universal scale the reason why this
was done is because the beyonders had
basically engineered the molecule man to
be that way and they were the reason why
he existed and the whole intention of
the beyonders was to basically detonate
all the molecule men across the
multiverse at the same time and blow up
the multiverse that was their goal and
so when dr doom had realized this he
worked alongside the molecule man owen
reese they went to an alternate reality
and they killed one of the molecule men
but when that happened it was detonating
a bomb the power of the molecule man in
that reality blew up the entire universe
and that's what started the incursions
in the first place and so that's why
when it comes to jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers over the course of
the story it's literally a race against
hunt it's basically doctor doom trying
to kill as many molecule men as possible
in order to ensure that because the
beyonders can't be defeated right no one
in the in the multiverse has that level
of power not even the living tribunal
like they literally killed it the
beyonders killed the living tribunal oh
it was a it was amazing dude there's
this point in the story when like you
find out that reed richards has sent
hank pym ant-man into the multiverse
hank pym comes back and he's like we are
so screwed and they're like what are you
talking about he's like okay so like i
got out into the multiverse and and
literally once i found like a true north
i was able to basically make my way
through the through the multiverse with
some level of direction i ended up
coming across what was basically a
massacre the like all the cosmic
entities were just being annihilated
by the beyonders and i wouldn't even
call it like an annihilation man that
indicates they stood a chance whatever
word you would use to indicate that
these beings are being destroyed by the
beyonders and they never had a chance to
even live that's what was happening to
them right whatever that adjective is
right to describe just this absolute
massacre that's happening so after all
these cosmic entities are destroyed the
living tribunal shows up right basically
the second most powerful being before
god hank pym is watching all this unfold
the beyonders kill the living tribunal
they obliterate that guy right it's like
that's the level of power we're talking
about right these these dudes were nuts
so and so because of the fact that dr
doom couldn't defeat them that what dr
doom was continuing to do was go through
the multiverse and basically kill as
many molecule man as he possibly could
as a race against what was going on the
other thing that he did is he formed the
black swans so they could start
destroying in cursive earth to try to
slow down the incursions so it's kind of
fighting a war on two fronts again all
this comes to a head at the end of the
story oh my god at the end of new
vendors and new avengers when basically
like like doctor doom and those guys
confront the beyonders and it's like
this giant container full of molecule
men like literally just these
ridiculously powerful guys they open it
up on right it's like doctor doom it's
molecule man prime you can call him that
and dr strange and like they're
literally facing these beyonders and
they open up this container of molecule
men who go flooding into the beyonders
and destroy them all and so with all
that power out there dr doom absorbs the
power of the honors and becomes god king
doom oh my god it was so good it was
just so ridiculously good i'm sorry guys
i'm i'm just saying i'm just saying man
it's one of the greatest stories ever
but that's basically the incursions by
the incursions of marvel comics were a
set of events which was created by dr
doom in an effort to stave off to be
honors attempts to destroy the
multiverse and he accidentally caused
universes to start crashing into each
other and that was basically it like
once that first universe was destroyed
there was no way to stop the incursions
it was inevitable the multiverse was
going to collapse but with that being
said guys uh we're going to bring this
to an end i hope you appreciate this
this explanation on the incursions i am
off social media until i'm done seeing
dr strange i'm not answering tweets i'm
not talking to people i'm not looking at
comments no nothing and i will see you
guys when i am done peace